welcome everyone this is part two in our
series on analysis methods in nlp we're
going to be talking about adversarial
testing this is an exciting mode because
as you'll see with a few dozen carefully
created examples you could learn
something really interesting about the
systems that you're developing
to start let's remind ourselves of how
evaluations standardly work in our field
at step one you create a data set from
some single homogeneous process it could
be that you scrape data from the web or
crowdsource a data set or label examples
yourself but the important thing is that
we typically do this as one single
process
and then in step two we divide that data
set into disjoint train and test sets
when we set the test set aside
and you do all your development on the
train set and only after all development
is complete you do an evaluation of your
system usually based on accuracy or some
similar metric on that held out test set
and then finally and this is the
important part you report the results of
that test set evaluation as providing an
estimate of the system's capacity to
generalize to new experiences
i hope you can hear in that that we're
being awfully generous to our systems at
step one we create a single data set
from a single process we hold out the
test set and we use that test set as our
device for measuring how well the system
is going to do if deployed out in the
real world but of course we know that
the real world is not created from some
single homogeneous process we know in
our heart of hearts that if we deploy
the system it will encounter examples
that are entirely unlike those that it
saw in training and assessment in this
standard mode and that might worry us
that we're overstating the capacity of
our systems to actually deal with the
complexity of the world
and adversarial evaluations are one way
that we can begin to close this gap here
so in adversarial evaluations we create
a data set by whatever you means you
like at step one
and you develop and assess the system
using that data set according to
whatever protocols you choose it could
be the standard evaluation mode if you
like here's the new part at step three
you develop a new test set of examples
that you suspect or know will be
challenging given your system and the
original data set that it was trained on
and then as usual after all your system
development is complete you evaluate the
system usually based on accuracy again
on that new test data set
and that's the result that you report as
your system's capacity to generalize to
new experiences at least of the sort
that you carved out in your adversarial
test set and the idea here is that in
having a distinction between the data
that we develop our system on and the
challenge problems that we pose we'll
get a better estimate of how our systems
perform on examples that are presumably
important examples that it's likely to
encounter if deployed in the real world
a brief historical note i think it's
fair to say that the idea of adversarial
testing traces all the way back to the
turing test which is introduced by
touring in this classic paper computing
machinery and intelligence the turing
test has an inherently adversarial
flavor to it because of course a
computer is trying to trick a human into
thinking that the computer is human
we also hear echoes of adversarial
testing in this classic article book
from terry winigrad called understanding
natural language there are discussions
in that book of the idea of constructing
examples that we know will stress test
our systems by probing to see whether
they have knowledge of what the world is
like and the true complexity of language
and then i think hector levesque really
elevated those winograd ideas into a
full-fledged testing mode in his paper
on our best behavior
let's look briefly at those winter guide
sentences or win a grad schema because
they're kind of interesting the idea is
that they will key into whether a system
has deep knowledge of the world and of
language
so we start with an example like the
trophy doesn't fit into the brown
suitcase because it's too small what's
too small
and the human answer is the suitcase
there's a minimally contrasting example
the trophy doesn't fit into the brown
suitcase because it's too large what's
too large here we answer the trophy and
presumably we do this because we can do
a kind of mental simulation involving
suitcases and trophies and figure out
how to answer these questions on that
basis
this next pair of examples is similar
but it keys more into kind of normative
social roles the council refused the
demonstrators a permit because they
feared violence who feared violence and
our standard answer drawing on standard
social roles is the council
again we have a minimally contrasting
example the council refused the
demonstrators of permit because they
advocated pilots who advocated violence
and here again drawing on default social
roles were inclined to answer the
demonstrators the intuition as i said is
that to resolve these questions given
how minimally different these examples
are you need to have a deep
understanding of the questions and the
context and also a deep understanding of
what our world is like
and then as i said the vet kind of
continues this and begins to systematize
it so he says we should pose questions
to our systems like could a crocodile
run a steeplechase
the intuition is clear the question can
be answered by thinking it through a
crocodile has short legs the hedges in a
steeplechase would be too tall for the
crocodile to jump over so no a crocodile
cannot run a steeplechase again a kind
of mental simulation that leads us to an
answer to this surprising question
and the idea is that questions like this
will not be susceptible to cheap tricks
as levesque says can we find questions
where cheap tricks like this will not be
sufficient to produce the desired
behavior this unfortunately has no easy
answer the best we can do perhaps is to
come up with a suite of multiple choice
questions carefully and then study the
sorts of computer programs that might be
able to answer them i think you can hear
in that what we now call the adversarial
testing mode
now i'm encouraging you to pose
adversarial tests to your systems and as
i said you can do that by constructing
just a few novel examples but we should
be aware of what we're doing
primary question what can adversarial
testing tell us and what can it tell us
about the systems that we're developing
so here are just a few considerations
that should guide your work in this area
first you don't need to be too
adversarial it could just be that you're
posing a challenge problem to assess
whether your system has an understanding
of a particular set of phenomena has my
system learned anything about numerical
terms does my system understand how
negation works does my system work with
a new style or genre these are challenge
problems that you could pose
open-mindedly and you might find that
your system is surprisingly good at them
second consideration we should be
thoughtful about the metrics we used as
i signaled to you before
the limitations of accuracy based
metrics like f1 and so forth are
generally left unaddressed by the
adversarial paradigm and that's because
we want a minimal contrast with our
standard evaluation modes but i think
you can hear in the mission statements
especially from levesque that we might
at some point want to break free of that
very restrictive mode and pose more
open-ended complex evaluations for our
systems that would involve requiring
them to offer their evidence and
interact with us to resolve uncertainty
about what they're supposed to be do all
of that is kind of left aside in the
standard adversarial mode and we should
be aware that it's a limitation
this next question is really
fundamentally important in adversarial
testing if you see a model failure is it
actually a failure of the model or of
the data set that the model was trained
on
lea would all pose this nicely what
should we conclude when a system fails
on a challenge data set
in some cases a challenge might exploit
blind spots in the design of the
original data set that would be a data
set weakness
in others the challenge might expose an
inherent inability of a particular model
family to handle certain natural
language phenomena that would be a model
weakness
now these are interestingly different
from the point of view of development in
our field we're apt to hope i think that
we find model weaknesses because those
are really fundamental discoveries but
we should be aware that it might be that
the system could have done well on our
adversarial test if it had just been
trained on the right kind of examples
and that would be a data set weakness
data set weaknesses are presumably
relatively easy for us to address we can
just supplement the training data with
examples of the relevant kind whereas
model weaknesses are pope are forcing us
to confront something that might be an
inherent limitation of the set of
approaches that we're taking a much more
fundamental insight
atticus geiger at all in this paper
offer a similar insight
in the context of being fair to our
models for any evaluation method we
should ask whether it's fair has the
model been shown data sufficient to
support the kind of generalization we're
asking of it unless we can say yes with
complete certainty we can't be sure
whether a failed evaluation traces to a
model limitation or a data limitation
that no model could overcome
and i'm emphasizing this because it's
surprisingly easy to fall into the trap
of thinking you have imposed an
unambiguous learning target when in fact
you have not
just think about the simple example here
human to human suppose i begin the
sequence three three five four and i say
to you what comes next in the sequence
now i might have in mind the number
seven
but the evidence that i have offered you
wildly under determines how to continue
the sequence and so i think it's fair to
say that no learning agent without a lot
of ambiguity could figure out what my
intended continuation is
and sometimes our adversarial tests have
this quality that the available data and
experiences of these systems just don't
fully disambiguate what our intended
learning targets are so we should be
aware of that those are data set
failings rather than model failings
now i can offer you a constructive set
of techniques to figure out whether
you're dealing with a data set weakness
or a model weakness and that falls under
the heading of inoculation by
fine-tuning from this wonderful paper
view it all that i quoted from before
so the unidol just remind us that in the
standard challenge evaluation mode we
train our system on some original data
set and then we test it on both the
original test set and our challenge test
set and our expectation is that we'll
see outcomes like this where the system
does really well on the original data
the original test set and really poorly
on the challenge test set
but when we see this outcome we should
ask why this is happening in particular
is a model weakness or a data set
weakness and their proposed method this
inoculation method works as follows
we're going to fine-tune our system on a
few of our challenge examples and then
re-test on both the original test set
and
the held out parts of the challenged
headset
when we do this there are kind of three
classes of outcome that you might see
the first would point to a data set
weakness if via this little bit of fine
tuning on the challenge data set we can
get good performance on the original and
the challenge data set that shows us
that in this original evaluation mode
the system just didn't see enough of the
relevant kinds from your of examples
from your adversarial tests to have any
hope of succeeding but a modest amount
of training on those examples leads it
to do fine
that's a data set weakness a model
weakness is what we might have in the
back of our minds for our adversarial
testing and this would be the case where
even though we have fine-tuned our
system on some of these challenge
examples its performance remains really
low even though the system can maintain
good performance on the original data
set and this is just like there is
something special about these new
examples and the model simply cannot get
traction
there's a third outcome that might be
really worrisome and they would trace
this to kind of like annotation
artifacts or label shift or something
like that and that's where in doing this
fine tuning on some challenge examples
we see degraded performance on both the
original data set and the challenge data
set and that would show that there is
something fundamentally confusing about
these advertising these adversarial
testing examples that are causing a lot
of problems for the system that we've
developed because even a modest amount
of fine tuning causes kind of
consequences to ripple through the
system that are impacting even
performance on the original data set
all right to close out this screencast
let me offer you two examples of
interesting adversarial tests in our
field beginning with the squad question
answering data set i showed you this
leaderboard from squad 2.0 at the start
of the quarter and the funny thing of
course is that you have to go all the
way to place 13 on the leaderboard to
find a system that is worse than our
estimate of human performance so we have
superhuman performance on squad but what
does that really mean squad was also the
site of one of the first really
systematic adversarial testing efforts
in our field this is from jia and lyon
and what they did is quite simple we
begin with squad examples where we have
passages and questions as inputs and the
system task is to answer the question
and we can count on the answer being a
literal substring in the passage that
the system was given the adversarial
thing that gia and yang did was simply
to append misleading sentences to the
ends of those passages
and what they found is that systems were
systematically misled by those final
sentences whereas humans could easily
ignore them systems were now inclined to
answer drawing on information from those
misleading new sentences
and this is kind of an interesting
dynamic because you might think well
we'll just train our system now on
passages that have these augmented
misleading sentences and then surely our
systems will be more robust
that might be true in some sense but of
course we could then just append
sentences to the start of the passages
and gia and young found that systems
were can now confused by the
appended initial sentences and they
started to give wrong answers in that
mode as well and you could kind of go
back and forth in this adversarial mode
showing that systems were worrisomely
easy to trick based on these simple um
appending of misleading sentences
now that's a very interesting
about adversarial evaluation mode what i
think is more interesting about the
outcomes is that if they begin to show
us just how different adversarial
testing can be
so here's the squad leader board the
original at the time of the paper as
well as the results of this adversarial
test and you can see first of all that
system performance has really plummeted
so this turns out to be highly
adversarial to these systems for
whatever reason i think it's more
interesting to note that the system
ranking has really been mixed up so it's
not like the system's uniformly dropped
in performance now as we move from the
original rank to the adversarial rank we
have like the first place system is now
in place five the second has dropped all
the way to place ten
um but the seventh place system is now
in first place it looks kind of chaotic
um here's a scatter plot where we have
the original system performance along
the x-axis and the adversarial system
performance along the y-axis and you can
see that it's kind of chaotic there's no
way that one predicts the other so
something very interesting has happened
and that's noteworthy because it looks
like that's meaningfully different from
what we do when we do standard
evaluations i don't have direct evidence
of this from squad but here's a case
where people took two classic image data
sets and simply created new test sets
according to the same protocols that
were used for the original data set test
sets and what you find is a very strong
correlation even though the examples are
new because it's the same protocol
system performance is highly predictive
in the sense that the original test
accuracy is perfectly correlated with
accuracy on these new test sets very
different from this adversarial mode
where something much more chaotic
happened so adversarial testing is
meaningfully different it seems from
standard evaluations
let's move to nli now this will tell us
two different lessons about how
adversarial testing can be informative
so we saw at the start of the course
that we now have super human performance
on the snli data set that's certainly
noteworthy
and we're reaching superhuman
performance on the multi-nli test set
we're sure to be there if we're not
already at the time of this screencast
but we've also seen that systems that
perform really well on these data sets
are often susceptible to adversaries in
the first screencast i showed you these
examples from glockner at all's breaking
nli paper
where they make simple modifications to
these hypotheses and find that systems
do not behave systematically with
respect to human intuitions about the
modified examples and that's the
worrisome part and they quantify that of
course and that you can see that the
best systems at the time up here were
doing pretty well on snli and their
performance plummeted on these new test
sets showing that this was for whatever
reason truly adversarial when it comes
to those systems
but i also presented this as a story of
progress right because i showed you that
in simply downloading roberta multi-noi
that is roberta fine-tuned on the
multi-nli data set you now have a device
where with no work you can essentially
solve this adversarial test i think
that's really striking and it points to
the fact that roberta unlike those
earlier models might truly have
systematic understanding of the relevant
kinds of lexical relationships that you
need to solve this adversarial test set
so that's an exciting outcome
here's a second outcome that you might
see and this is from the nikon paper
that does a wide battery of different
adversarial tests on multi-nli data
they did a bunch of things like antonyms
i love the cinderella story contradicts
i hate the cinderella story just drawing
on lexical knowledge they asked about
numerical reasoning across these two
premises
word overlap and this is a little bit
different in that you're doing something
like just inserting material that you
might think is going to be distracting
in the mode of the squad adversary and
seeing what effects that has and the
same thing for negation adding on to the
end information
that's going to be misleading for a
system and also includes a lot of
negation elements there are a few other
modes that i didn't have space for it's
a very rich paper with a very
fine-grained breakdown of how systems do
on these different adversarial problems
here's a picture of the data set and
here's a breakdown and i think the
overall takeaway is that the numbers
across the board are very low on these
adversaries
and so that that's interesting and it
looks like even top performing systems
for multi-noi are stumbling with these
problems that we surely want our systems
to be able to solve if we're going to
call them true common sense reasoners
however this was actually the basis for
a number of the experiments in that
inoculation by fine-tuning paper that i
quoted from before
here's a kind of rough picture of the
performance results that they report on
different subsets of that adversarial
test on multi-nli and you can see that
it shows all the different outcomes that
we discussed under the heading of
inoculation by fine-tuning to simplify
things just focus in on the green lines
the ones with dots are the original
system performance and the ones with
crosses are on the challenge data set so
this first column here is identifying
data set weaknesses what you're seeing
is that as we fine tune on more examples
from the challenge data set going along
the x-axis here we very quickly get a
system that's actually good at this
challenge problem right after just about
50 examples the system is basically
learning to solve the word overlap and
negation problems although negation
takes a little bit longer at 400
examples so that's a case where the
original systems were failing not
because of any intrinsic property of the
models being used but rather because the
data clearly just didn't have enough
information to resolve these learning
targets
we also see outcome 2 which is a model
weakness again follow the green lines
and you can see here that for spelling
errors and length mismatch no amount of
fine-tuning on challenge examples helps
these systems get traction on these
problems that's these flat lines here
and that's showing that there's
something fundamentally wrong possibly
with these models they are just unable
to solve these two challenge problems
and then we also see the third artifact
for numerical reasoning you'll notice
that system performance is kind of
really chaotic here and that's
suggesting that there is something
importantly and problematically
different
about these challenge examples because
fine-tuning on them causes the system to
become really chaotic in its predictions
when we get degraded performance not
only on the challenge set but also on
the original data set showing that we've
done something quite disruptive
so this is really interesting that in
this case from this battery of
adversarial tests we see all these
different outcomes pointing us to all
sorts of different lessons about what
action we should take to make these
systems more robust